located in the northern part of Vietnam  other 400 islands and stunning isolated  beaches of lan ha bay while  geographically it is part of halong bay  a popular tourist site lan ha bay is in  a different province making it more  difficult to access and allowing it to  retain its secluded charm the area is  rich in biodiversity and is home to 200  species of fish 500 species of mollusk  and larger marine animals nestled  amongst the 400 islands is a small  fishing village the village is only  accessible by boat and is a two-hour  ride from the nearest mainland Cat Ba  Island  each house in this floating village have  homes where they farm fish but puns are  the only thing found in the front yards  of these locals goats are placed on the  islands nearby to braise and build  muscles before they are sold by the  villagers although it is Vietnam's less  visited Bay lan ha bay stunning views  will leave a lasting impression  [Music]  [Music]